now we turn to memorial day weekend and
the unofficial start of summer which
will be a lot more expensive to
celebrate this year
aaa expects more than 39 million
americans to travel at least 50 miles
from home this weekend nearly 35 million
will be driving paying near record high
prices for gas
another 3 million or more will travel by
plane and as errol barnett shows us
travelers will be experiencing more
packed flights this weekend
flyers are likely noticing few empty
seats this weekend a site unlikely to
change anytime soon there are
approximately 13 percent fewer flights
available over the next few months
compared to the same time before the
pandemic
and delta announced thursday it's
reducing its schedule by 2 percent or
100 flights per day partly due to
increased covert case rates
speaking to cbs news last week delta
highlighted its ongoing hiring efforts
for positions throughout the company
we're still recovering a lot of ways and
both our system and our network
we have a lot of new employees about 30
percent of our of our team are new 15 of
our workforce is new since last october
staffing limitations for southwest ceo
to reduce his airline schedule by 7
percent bob jordan says his current
hiring surge is essential carefully
review the safety information this will
be our largest hiring year hiring period
in our history but stress isn't only in
the skies with drivers facing record gas
prices most americans are taking road
trips this weekend one of the estimated
35 million is jeff kapke of indiana
it costs about 130 dollars to fill the
car's tank up it's not going to
deter us from hitting the road
capke and his wife are on a journey to
show their sons all 50 states before
they turn 18. we want to show them our
magnificent country there's so much to
see and to do
and with poor weather rolling through
the country right now drivers and flyers
should leave early if possible and plan
for disruptions some of the airlines are
offering travel waivers for flyers in
the path of some of these storms who
will need to change plans but the bottom
line here is we could see pre-pandemic
levels of travel with fewer airline
seats available so gail patience is
paramount